[Música]
y
sí
ah
y
[Música]
hola buenas tardes cómo están mi nombre
como dijeron recién los chicos es maría
soledad bazán y hoy estoy aquí para
hablarles de lo que considero que es un
modo en que las personas podemos
construir nuestro progreso que podemos
construir lo que queremos en la vida
cómo podemos avanzar para esto se me
ocurrió comenzar con invitarlos a
imaginar qué significa estar en el
desierto
cuando nos ponemos a pensar en esa
situación
cuando cuando trataba de pensar en cómo
transmitirles esto decía me voy imagina
una situación bien adversa y enseguida
apareció en mi mente un desierto
porque yo pienso y lo sitúo a ustedes en
esa misiva en esto de tener que
atravesar un desierto y me imagino un
lugar inhóspito con muchísima arena en
donde empiezo a sentir cansancio no hay
nada para comer no hay nada para tomar
siento seguramente mucha soledad y mucha
desprotección y la pregunta es cómo
podemos lograr salir de eso cómo salir
de una situación similar
pienso que por lo menos tenemos que
luchar con todas las herramientas que
tengamos disponibles tenemos que dejarlo
todo ahí si no lo vamos a poder lograr
llegar a un lugar en donde nos podamos
sentir tranquilos y calmados en un
refugio con cierto amparo que esa agua
vieron que en todo desierto siempre hay
un oasis pero tenemos que encontrarlo
así es que empecé a pensar a partir de
esto
y es lo que verdaderamente condiciona
que las personas podamos obtener lo que
queremos o que podemos resolver una
situación adversa porque no sé si
ustedes habrán escuchado yo lo escuché
en muchas oportunidades que el contexto
del cual provenimos suele determinar las
posibilidades que podemos acceder
yo creo que esto no es estrictamente
cierto me propongo por medio de esta
charla invitarlos a cuestionar esa
creencia yo creo por el contrario que
como dices definirá el mejor modo de
predecir el futuro es creando lo es
construirlo las personas por ahí
tendemos a creer que
si no tenemos por ejemplo determinados
recursos materiales no vamos a poder
algo de lo cual que nos propongamos o
que si tenemos algún tipo de indecisión
o un miedo no lo vamos a poder superar y
esto no es así nosotros tenemos el poder
de construir lo que elijamos a hacer
como dice walt disney piensa sueña cree
y atrévete parecen ofrece hecha pero
esto no es fácil de afrontar yo creo que
el progreso lo que las personas podemos
lograr de 3-d
de poseer determinadas actitudes de
tener definido el sueño el proyecto al
que queremos avanzar y de las
herramientas que tenemos disponibles
para poder lograrlo a qué me refiero con
esto no sé si les habré pasado de estar
en una situación en donde una actitud
ayudó a que lograrán sus objetivos como
por ejemplo tener seguridad en sí mismos
tener paciencia ser tolerantes y a su
vez también alguna actitud dificultó que
pudieran concretar lo que ustedes
querían por ejemplo quejarse
excesivamente echarle la culpa a otro en
lugar de responsabilizarse
no tener confianza no tener una buena
autoestima estas cosas realmente pueden
entorpecer mucho lo que queremos lograr
con herramientas yo me refiero al medio
que voy a utilizar para lograr esto como
hago porque muchas veces no es que no
podamos lograr lo que queremos el sueño
sino que a veces no sabemos no tenemos
bien definido que queremos hacia dónde
queremos ir por eso no lo podemos no lo
podemos afrontar porque no lo podemos
poner en palabras y otras veces sabemos
que queremos pero tenemos miedo
y empezamos a pensar de este modo no no
me sale no puedo no me va a ir bien no
me va bien lo quiero hacer pero me
parece que no tengo oportunidad e
instantáneamente instalamos una
situación de auto boicot que nos va a
llevar a fracasar una y otra vez
entonces hoy les traigo una herramienta
que me parece muy importante y necesaria
para salir adelante que se llama tablero
de visión yo tengo un equipo de trabajo
como decían hace un ratito de los chicos
en la presentación con el cual emprendo
trabajando en problemáticas
psicosociales en prevención
y cada vez que queremos resolver un
problema lo que hacemos es aplicar este
tablero de visión pero también lo
consejo para cada ocasión en donde
tienen que destrabar alguna dificultad a
nivel efectivo o personal
el tablero de visión
aquí está su nombre nos indica hacia
dónde ir hacia dónde tenemos que mirar y
tiene estas etapas diferentes
el propósito el examen la batalla y la
acción nos indica a través de una serie
de pasos lógicos que tenemos que hacer
para llegar a lo que queremos lograr
el propósito implica establecer que
quiero como dije hace un ratito muchas
veces el problema no es que no podamos
lograr lo que queremos sino que no
sabemos y para saber que queremos muchas
veces nos tenemos que preguntar quiénes
somos si por ejemplo dándole un ejemplo
básico si una persona descubre cuáles
son sus talentos cuáles son sus
habilidades dice por ejemplo soy bueno
para el deporte específicamente para el
básquet quizás quiera destacarse en eso
quizás quiere hacer basquetbolista
entonces poder definir quién soy me iba
a ayudar un poquito más a poder
determinar qué es lo que quiere
un ejercicio introspectivo difícil pero
ayuda el examen son las acciones que
puedo emprender para llegar a eso que
quiero lograr y necesariamente me va a
influir en esto de abandonar mi zona de
confort porque el hecho de que nosotros
estemos cómodos en nuestra vida no
significa necesariamente que seamos
felices que estemos contentos que
estemos a gusto sino que hacernos estas
preguntas muchas veces hacen que nos
demos cuenta que queremos cambiar pero
que tenemos miedo o que no sabemos cómo
hacerlo la batalla finalmente antes de
lograr la realización de lo que queremos
hacer es el momento en donde
identificamos los obstáculos muchas
veces me han pasado de hablar con
personas que dicen no poder lograr algo
pero no saben explicar por qué me
preguntaste pero por qué por qué no te
sale y no luego no lo pueden definir es
porque no tienen identificados cuáles
son los obstáculos que le impiden
avanzar
con un se pone a pensar cuáles son los
obstáculos que hacen que tropieces en
lugar de que avance va a poder llegar
más rápidamente la acción cuáles
pónganse pensar ustedes en estos
momentos cuáles son los obstáculos que
le impiden a ustedes alcanzar sus
objetivos
y miedo como dijimos recién es la falta
de seguridad la falta de confianza que
se traduce en un no puedo en la falta de
apoyo de sus familias quizás que también
muchas veces condicionan en lo que
queremos hacer la falta de recursos
económicos puede haber muchísimos
obstáculos que si no los podemos poner
en palabras se van a dar una y otra vez
y van a entorpecer nuestro camino yo les
quería compartir una una gravísima
historia de superación porque me parece
que ilustra muy bien esto que acabo de
comentarles
y es la historia de una niña que
descubre a los 78 años de edad que
quería ser escritora sabía escribir muy
bien de hecho a los 78 años de edad los
chicos están aprendiendo a escribir y
esta persona escribió poesía es decir
que era algo para lo que era habilidosa
de hecho tenía él
el hobby de leer diccionarios
o uno es muy apasionado por las letras o
es raro si la diccionarios una de dos
esta persona tenía esa habilidad pero
tenía dos obstáculos muy importantes que
era la falta de confianza en sí misma y
la falta de apoyo de sus padres su madre
sin ir más lejos un día se sentó con
ella porque ella había decidido ser
escritora en lo que había elegido para
su vida y le dijo hija me parece que no
está bien esa decisión
los escritores viven y mueren en la
miseria
fuertes para un niño eso es algo
bastante atemorizante seguramente las
palabras no sirven para nada no son
importantes y no te van a dar de comer
entonces esta niña crece y decide
estudiar una carrera muy distinta
en la universidad terminar su carrera
obedece su madre deja la escritura a un
lado y al cabo de un tiempo se enferma
muy gravemente
le descubren para ser más precisa un
tumor en el páncreas una cosa bien grave
esta situación le genera muchísimo miedo
pero además muchísima tristeza porque se
da cuenta devalúa su vida y se da cuenta
que lo que estuvo haciendo hasta ese
momento lo estuvo haciendo más por los
demás que por sí misma es que lo único
que quería con todo su corazón que era
escribir no lo supo defender no supo
animarme tener la audacia arriesgarse a
defender lo que quería hacer
por suerte por suerte esta niña que ya
era una mujer adulta logre recuperarse
esta situación porque ese tumor resultó
ser benigno si bien fue una intervención
muy muy difícil logró salir adelante y
dos años después decidió publicar un
libro
yo creo que si hoy estuviera en esta en
este auditorio esa mamá
probablemente esa niña quisiera decirle
mamá las palabras sí son importantes de
hecho las palabras me sirvieron para
escribir esta charla te de c's
creo que
lo que intento dejarles
con esta charla es que es muy importante
en la vida poder animarse a defender lo
que nosotros construimos que queremos no
lo que nos digan
el contexto nos condiciona pero no por
lo social o por lo económico sino porque
nos dice cómo pensar sobre la vida sobre
determinadas cosas entonces el desafío
está en poder incorporar otras ideas
otras creencias que al principio nos va
a costar mucho trabajo poder hacerlo nos
va a generar conflicto temor a angustia
pero después va a generar el aprendizaje
e incluso una nueva perspectiva del
futuro para nuestra vida porque cambiar
de actitud muchas veces nos coloca en el
camino correcto
y para finalizar
quisiera decirles esto que es lo que yo
pienso y creo con todo mi corazón
el éxito no depende de dónde venimos
sino de adónde vamos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]